buenas tardes arrancado esta cumbre
considerada como histórica para el
futuro de la humanidad chile el país
presidente de la cob 25 ha entregado
oficialmente al reino unido- esta
responsabilidad con la presidencia de la
cob 26 la presidenta de la 25 la chilena
carolina schmidt ha pedido a los países
del g7 los más poderosos 20 que se
reúnen en este momento en roma' que
cumplan con los compromisos adquiridos y
dijo que es optimista aunque reconoce
que hay mucho que hacer ha dicho además
que la humanidad está viendo el impacto
que se ha creado en el cambio climático
en la temperatura del planeta y por ello
hay que actuar rápidamente agradeció a
españa la el recibimiento del 25 porque
recordemos que tenía prevista realizarse
en chile pero no pudo ser así por el
estallido social que vivió ese país y
también el presidente a los charm a el
británico ha recibido la con 26 diciendo
la importancia que esto tiene para la
humanidad que debe ser un punto de
inflexión y también ha dicho que
tendremos que asegurarnos que el glasgow
cumpla lo que parís prometió bueno y qué
se puede esperar realmente de esta
cumbre del clima en glasgow
arranca con un sabor agridulce por un
lado la humanidad requiere acciones
urgentes porque hemos visto cada vez más
lo devastador del cambio climático hemos
visto olas de calor inundaciones y
sequías por ello debe actuarse
rápidamente y por otro lado el primer
ministro británico y también al observar
ha reconocido la dificultad que puede
tener el que la cob no alcance esos
objetivos por ello es difícil pero sería
exitoso si se cumple el acuerdo de parís
del 2005 para mantener controlado la
temperatura de la tierra en 1.5 y sobre
todo que la política se imponga y
entonces más allá de los anuncios se
cumplan reales acciones para el futuro
de la humanidad para cada uno de
nosotros